[Music]
North Korea is a bit of a black box
right it's got this rogue nuclear
program it's under heavy international
sanctions school ogz there's famines the
people appear to worship this deified
kid of a national leader to understand
why that is you really have to go back
to 1910 who in japan first colonized
Korea and Japan at the time was its own
super crazy fascist Imperial state which
Americans know about because we fought a
war with them Japan wanted to convince
Koreans that they were a subset of the
Japanese race and to rally them to the
Imperial cause and then Japan collapsed
1945 the North came under Soviet
occupation but the ideology stayed there
so we think of North Korea as like this
last holdover of soviet-style communism
but actually it's the last holdover of
Japanese fascism and you still see that
today North Koreans are told that they
are the purest race on earth and that
their superiority means that they need a
strong leader to protect them from the
outside world and then they have this
leader who's kind of deified because
he's a holdover from the Japanese
Emperor who was actually you know a
quasi-religious figure so then in 1991
the Soviet Union collapses
stop giving North Korea all these
subsidies and the North Korean
government needed to find a new way to
keep its citizens support because they
were so poor that they could not feed
their own people and one in ten North
Koreans starve to death so that's when
Kim jong-il who was the leader at the
time came up with the Sun gun policy
military first which is this big lie
they tell the country that they're
constantly at this like low boil war
with the entire outside world especially
the American imperialist dogs so you
have to give up everything towards the
military cause it's really effective
everybody buys into it there's studies
that show that even North Koreans who
believe the country and see how poor
North Korea's most of them actually come
back willingly when Kim jong-il died
there were millions of North Koreans
crying in the street and even defectors
say that was more real than fake which
is kind of amazing given that the
country is really poor and 1% of its
population lives in physicans
and then one effect of this that works
really well in the North Korean
government's favor is that this
militarism also distracts the US and the
rest of the outside world so we're so
worried about their nuclear program and
the crazy attacks in South Korea that we
actually don't bother that much with the
way they treat their own people who are
the real victims of the North Korean
system
[Music]